[Music]
this world built by men
for men to protect them holy wars say
amen with aggression throwing money out
of pocket getting it intercepted
kaepernick could stand and never get
respected
they were writing history books down in
texas see they systems getting bigger
when you asking questions
who am i to call myself a blessing if
the god in me is constantly getting
arrested
the darker the buried the darker the
sentence i too sing america
so don't tell me to pipe down or sit at
the table my granny used to wipe down ah
[ __ ] system let's come with look at
all the dead bodies laying on the ground
but still we rise like maya angelou step
outside playing d'angelo chicago smile
for tim buck too
now many avenues for us to live up to so
what you want
benjamin or aretha franklin respect on
your name or a couple green faces
my name is malcolm xavier london
when my mother was pregnant with me she
watched denzel washington
as malcolm x and in the theater
she said that's going to be the name of
my son
for baby shoes we only got two c's
4c 10c 11c
and then you sizes we got 6 and a half
and 7u
those are the only sizes we got left and
i'm so very sorry for the bottom of my
heart
we've been trying to organize this it's
a lot of shows it's a lot of people
but we will be doing this again
i grew up on the west side of chicago
which is both
all the things you hear on the news and
there's also so much more
the things the world told me about where
i was from
make you you know not love yourself
and make you question your own existence
and
the capabilities of the people around
you and even yourself
i'm gonna give you a question all right
there's gonna be person a person b
i'm gonna give you a question i want
person a to ask person b
this question over and over again
personal b
is your job to give a different answer
every time
the question is who are you
who are you a rapper who are you a black
man
who are you ambitious teen who are you
hard worker
a little kid always alone classical high
school graduate opportunistic lost
human troubled ambitious broken
ah
shortly after trayvon martin was killed
i had a mentor
come up with this idea called occupy
whiteness
and we would go around the city where
folks who looked like us traditionally
weren't
welcomed now there's no
sign in chicago that says no blacks
allowed
right but there is an aura
and there is a policing
that happens that make you feel like
you're not welcome there
and so we would go to the art museum or
the expensive restaurant downtown and
just be black as [ __ ]
you